[Music]
Claire are we already in a political
crisis well well we are but we're in a
political crisis but just on the weather
we blame politicians I think to go back
before breakfast and partly to explain
what happened in that referendum I think
we actually have to go back to a phrase
that was coined by Margaret Thatcher
which was Tina there is no alternative
Francis Fukuyama said the end of history
and that was very much this idea that
there is no that's this is it right and
politicians we we entered what was then
described as a post ideological period
and what you got was that you this
ripped the heart out of and the soul out
of Principles political parties that
stood for anything and you got the
emergence of kind of managerial a kind
of utilitarian politicians who tinkered
around but basically thought that the
big stuff I didn't need to be interfered
with and I think that as a consequence
of that we were all aware of the the way
that things have happened there is a
political class they speak the same
language they feel very comfortable with
each other they know each other they
it's not it's not kind of they went to
the same schools once it's more than
it's a kind of way of being and it
doesn't have any of the spirit and the
dynamism that politics used to have
which was a for the fight for the
contestation of the future so basically
if you then look what happens is they
become more comfortable talking to each
other than they do talking to the
electorate and one of the things that
was hilarious after brexit was all these
politicians who said I don't recognize a
country I lived in right and you know
who is expecting that and you do that
well get out more I mean they were your
constituency voted it's not my fault you
never talk to them it was a shock to the
to the elite but that is actually
because they had no feel for what the
mood of the country was so in that sense
I think there's a political crisis
around politicians look as they're
horrible people but because they're not
people of principle and honor who stand
for ideological difference
that's what
the things I'm concerned about the
number of times that people will say to
me you know this sovereignty stuff you
know what's a lot about I don't
understand it because one of the things
that happened as a consequence of
technocracy was that all that
politicians did was that they basically
did Qi people you know they're kind of
paternalistically intervened in people's
lives rather than seeing them as equals
and citizens who they treated with
respect and as a consequence of which
peoples had their agency removed from
them they no longer felt that they had
any purpose I mean people think that the
brexit vote had something to do with
being left behind in the economy and the
financial crisis that's only a small
aspect of it the reason why that slogan
take back control resonated with people
was because they felt that they have no
control over their future and I will
fight for democratic rights for the
suffragettes and the Chartists all these
people was about saying we take control
of our destiny we have taken seriously
and they felt that that been squeezed
out for decades so then they actually
thought right I'm going to say what I
want to happen in the future and as a
consequence I think the politicians
don't actually know because they're
their technocratic were had a very
narrow political experience they don't
actually know how to lead or interact
with people in those circumstances so in
that sense I think that the political
elites have been shown up and I think it
was dan dan Hannon yesterday said you
know we have many pygmies in politics
and many of us will recognize that it's
also relates to the EU final point on on
this on this one which is that part of
the problem about being in the European
Union which makes me laugh is the idea
that it's kind of like 28 countries
harmoniously fighting for peace and
prosperity and we all sit around holding
hands and this is a massive trade bloc
it's about exploiting as much as
possible ways of making money out of
millions of people throughout Europe I
mean talk to the Greek people if you
want to know what it feels like being in
a eurozone country this is fortress
Europe that actually accrues upon itself
a huge amout pound now this is where you
might be surprised
I don't blame
the bureaucrats in Brussels for the
growth of your EU power it is a deal
done by the ruling classes of each and
every one of those countries to remove
decision-making from their domestic
electorates and to take it somewhere
else if you look at most EU laws they
were suggested by British politicians
but what British politicians did was
rather than taking it to us where they
might have to have a row they took it to
Brussels got it passed there came back
to us and said we've got no choice it's
a year use fault so I do understand that
the EU stuff has been an alibi but every
single ruling class in every European
country thinks that by the way I was
influenced quite heavily by some of the
green euro skeptics who used to argue
this sort of stuff not that long ago and
actually made an impact on me I was
influenced by Tony Benn saying it that's
why it's anti-democratic but as a
consequence of that institutions in this
country have lost the ability to deal
with politics
so the NME just one example I was
talking to them before the referendum
and they said and there was a joke oh if
we do believe we won't know what to do
because our policy Department is made up
of lawyers who spend their whole time in
Brussels interpreting the law we
actually haven't got an agricultural
policy and every single institution was
like that
they related to policymaking by going
and discussing it somewhere else not
with us now I haven't think we're more
important than them and that is not
because of a nationalist or an nativist
is because I'm a Democrat and the way
democracy happens is in the nation-state
where your vote matters for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts in ideas her iai
TV
you